good man my name playing on plays sick
in the horror game for the very first
time this one is called well it's a
tree's cider and blood curds now let's
head it wrong even though it says right
there
we're gonna play on normal cuz just
don't judge me all right episode 1
chapter 1 as far as I'm concerned it's
pretty much like an episodic TV show
thingy thing I don't really know if I
know correct
probably not in a village 19 no wait
what are now I supposed to read that
that's redonkulous yes I did say the
donkey Oh a bear
why would the bear do that oh what the
hell oh what the hell is he wearing a
cape for it this is like
all right what the hell I don't know
they're gonna rape her
I'm just saying I didn't say it well I
guess I did yeah the sword I want to
sword
I love swords Oh secret penetrator that
all they said
that's pretty sure they kill neck oh no
this is a movie or is it like animated I
don't really I understand oh no it's
kind of hard see oh it's not I guess oh
he's a hero I'm here all right
I believe sorry what watching a harm
Oh No I want these glasses and I want
them now cutting [ __ ] knows glasses I
think hey there he is
that's the HERA oh why would he be
stopped I would just keep browning on
this thing [ __ ] goddamn Sanka Howard
right a high school student visiting the
side and the same day as it god damn it
how I ride just can't get candy cart any
light these days terrifying ordeal Oh No
okay and he has a pair of earring -
isn't that lovely
what is that what is that why is he
pointing why was he pointing a phone oh
I see what this is going where are the
cops when you need them that's a good
question
that's a good I keep asking myself every
time I'm stuck on the toilet what okay
video camera at what did we actually get
to play soon I don't know if I want to
play anyone I feel more safe watching
Howard right Haga second oh and it's
almost 12 you know that's the hour of
the ghost
I think escaped from who no I don't like
escaping
can't we just hug him hug the police
officer I think that would be a better
story - I think it thinks but that's
just my opinion all right I click in any
product ah oh look at yes
no oh and it shows the same time I had
sad check all right oh oh I love this
show and I love that's the pointing man
again what is he pointing at let me just
see if I can get the controls ready for
this
that's the bitch-slap butter there we go
alright I got that nailed crouch and
spam let's just crouch
awesome driving need another may be
driving watch okay all right hiding
somewhere come on go go go go ah don't
jerk me holy [ __ ] I'm innocent
whoa whoa whoa don't dance in front of
the clip sob dad's in front of the cop
holy [ __ ] but if we go alright I know
this cigs act like a boss zigzag like a
bot and slappy snow there we go and run
ha ha ha alright I got this what wrong
with the food get on well this is still
coming I think we're safe for now
find a place to hide what about over
here
no what about gotta find a place I got
hello where do I hand y8 and oh my god I
got it no problem us
señoritas in signora what the hell is on
there hey Lex are you all right
hey can I poke him with something cool
oh no hi
jordu dad tell them what I am I know
you're not oh shut up woman
all right I think it was a man but it's
okay what the hell was he doing
I liked his breathing no creep is hell
you little rat you almost told me where
I am silly woman man whatever you are
transvestite all right if this was real
I would probably just hang out here for
a while I'm just saying I would hang out
here for a long while but I think we
have to leave that's the problem
all right so now what do we do now go
back I guess
oh okay good Oh whatever to you
I'll tickle your feet for this pickup
sake but don't pick that sake bottle up
oh it's sake bottle Venice time
that's what to get barrel what the [ __ ]
pants up oh oh oh oh go near go away
I got it Oh
kind of cozy in here smells like
strawberries mmm whoa
[Music]
I don't like it
has anyone seen and it who's he talking
to he's talking to her I know it
hey welcome to Barrow Sunday oh no I
don't know oh no oh no don't look at me
avoid eye contact holy [ __ ] that guy has
swag what what much mr. yo-yo no
comprendo
señoritas oh no breathing mode sexy mode
hissing initiated
what the hell is this makes us sons stop
raining so sexy no it doesn't why would
you lie like that I guess oh no oh no oh
no oh that's oh what's he looking at oh
no he can totally see me Oh
escaped out the back door
I'm good here actually alright let's
[ __ ] do this
I'm sorry I don't even know if you can
hear me when I'm that far back
alright one man you better not tell him
where I am don't give it out enough
Corbin stop looking like us all right I
have a sake bottle backdoor booth oh
dude why are you bathing in blood bro
all right grace door we go out in this
active open woman oh no oh yes yes yes
sir
all right now what now what we get out
of here
that's what you do oh no oh no all right
let's turn off the flashlight there we
go perfect
switch to shovel shovel I missed you all
right
whoo-hoo the food settle down Megan
wanted us less this is for Oprah
this is Ferrara there we go there we go
eh ate all of it eh more did I make it
now
shovel the vengeance ah all right not
bad for a shovel in there Prentice must
say I only just recent holy [ __ ]
SAP complaining woman it's not a big
deal all he did was Oh
I'm not gonna all get raped by policeman
that's what it yet battle [ __ ] get
battle oh oh oh I don't know
that is a shifter worthy indeed mission
accomplished
all right I think our end is here thanks
me I can do to make my screen to work
all right how long haven't I can't see
with this new software on our list what
not since I completed me Shawny I'm
gonna hear a stop crying woman Jason
Kreis they're never allowed to stop
crying all right I don't know how to pot
it's a Playstation [ __ ] anyway sorry
mystic short episode I can't feel a star
now I don't know how was the next
episode alright okay alright anyway like
and favors you enjoy you want to see
more of this let's play I would prefer
if I play more than one absurdly say
let's finish it
I haven't see you next episode more
video that I make in compensation what I
do
music buds safety Bailey don't shake
Thalia
whatever just go here